[Música]
una delegación del Estado colombiano y
otra de la guerrilla del eln reunidas en
Venezuela anunciaron que tras la primera
semana de noviembre
reanudarán los diálogos de paz las
conversaciones estarán auspiciadas Por
Cuba Noruega y Venezuela tenemos informe
desde Caracas
Este martes el senado ruso aprobó por
unanimidad las leyes que ratifican los
tratados de anexión a Rusia de las
regiones de doniesc lugans gerson y
saporiya solo falta la firma del
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin para
finalizar el proceso de integración
unilateral
el premio Nobel de física de 2022 fue
atribuido en partes iguales a Alan
aspect John floser y anton salengers por
sus descubrimientos en el ámbito de la
mecánica cuántica
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
de nuestra región porque una delegación
del Estado colombiano y otra de la
guerrilla del eln reunidas en Venezuela
anunciaron que retomarán los diálogos de
paz después de la primera semana de
noviembre ambas partes acordaron volver
a las mesas de diálogo en un proceso que
estará auspiciado Por Cuba Noruega y
Venezuela recordemos que las
conversaciones de paz entre el gobierno
de Bogotá y la guerrilla fueron
congeladas bajo la presidencia de Iván
Duque y ahora reiniciar este proceso es
el el primer paso hacia la paz total a
la que aspira el presidente Gustavo
Petro conectamos ahora con nuestra
corresponsal en Caracas Daniela Zambrano
Daniela qué detalles tenemos del anuncio
en la firma de este acuerdo conjunto
estuvieron presentes Antonio García el
máximo comandante del Ln y alias Pablo
Beltrán y por parte del gobierno
colombiano el alto comisionado para la
paz Danilo Rueda y el senador Iván
Cepeda se firmó acá mis espaldas en la
antigua sede presidencial de la casona
sobre cuándo se va a reanudar este
proceso de diálogo dijeron que era para
la segunda semana de Noviembre sin
embargo no especificaron fecha tampoco
sede aseguraron que se va a continuar
con lo que se había acordado bajo el
gobierno de Juan Manuel Santos en 2016
de que la sede fuera rotativa entre los
países garantes Venezuela Noruega y Cuba
sin embargo no quisieron especificar
dónde sería esa reunión consultados
además sobre si una de las condiciones
sería el cese al fuego y la liberación
de Rehenes el máximo comandante del Ln
dijo que si el problema era las armas el
cese de las armas ya estuviese
solucionado Que para él ese no era la
principal preocupación sino solucionar
los problemas de fondo que originaron el
conflicto respondieron las preguntas a
la prensa por separado o hubo bastante
hermetismo bastante control a los medios
de comunicación en este pronunciamiento
y trataron de no ofrecer mayores
detalles que lo he leído en el
comunicado también estuvieron presentes
representantes de la misión de
verificación de la Organización de
Naciones Unidas y también por parte del
gobierno venezolano Cuba y Noruega
países grandes Daniela Muchísimas
gracias por este reporte estaremos muy
atentos a todo este proceso esta
reanudación de los diálogos Buenas
tardes para usted
cambiamos de información Este martes el
senado ruso aprobó por unanimidad la
anexión de donesk lugans gerson y
saporiya a la federación rusa a la
espera de la firma del presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin que supone el punto y
final a este proceso unilateral el
conflicto sigue escalando sobre el
terreno por otro lado el kremlin informó
que 200.000 hombres se han alistado al
ejército en el marco de la movilización
parcial obligatoria kiev por otro lado
reivindica nuevos avances en el sur y en
el este del país Marta Moya con los
detalles la decisión se ha tomado por
unanimidad tal como ocurrió en la
víspera en la duma Este martes los
miembros del senado ratificaron la
incorporación de las autoproclamadas
republicas de doniach y logans y las
provincias de gersor izacoritja como
parte de la federación rusa los
territorios anexados unilateralmente por
el kremlin suponen cerca del 18% del
territorio conocido internacionalmente a
Ucrania en paralelo Moscú sigue
entrenando a miles de soldados para
llevarlos al frente de batalla tras su
llamado a la movilización parcial de
hace dos semanas
al día de hoy más de 200.000 personas se
han incorporado a las fuerzas armadas he
ordenado que se les proporcione a todos
ellos uniformes y otros equipos
necesarios y se les nombre en puestos
militares el personal de servicio debe
ser enviada a las zonas de combate
después del fin del entrenamiento y el
ensayo
en el terreno la arremetida continúa
desde Ucrania temen que los ataques del
ejército ruso contra infraestructuras
estratégicas puedan redoblarse con la
llegada del Invierno no obstante en kiev
siguen reivindicando sus avances en el
sur y el oeste liberando según las
autoridades varias localidades a las
orillas del río ni pro Los logros
militares los reflejan estos soldados
ucranianos izando banderas en pueblos de
jarqui y gerson
hay nuevos asentamientos liberados en
varias regiones continúan los combates
feroces en muchas áreas del diferente
Pero la perspectiva de estas
hostilidades sigue siendo obvia cada vez
más ocupantes están tratando de escapar
el ejército enemigo está sufriendo más y
más bajas y hay una comprensión
creciente de que Rusia cometió un error
al ir a la guerra contra Ucrania pese a
los llamados de nuevas sanciones
internacionales
Moscú sigue escalando su ofensiva dentro
y fuera de Ucrania
y cambiamos de nuevo de información
igual que hizo ayer el líder supremo de
Irán el ayatolá alija menei hoy el
presidente iraní Ibrahim Racing acusó a
Estados Unidos y a Israel de organizar
las protestas por la muerte de maxa Amin
recordemos que la joven murió tras ser
detenida por la policía de la moral y
que fue el mismo día de su funeral el 17
de septiembre cuando se desató el
movimiento contra la represión y la
brutalidad del régimen de Teherán raíz y
pidió unidad nacional mientras las
protestas se extienden por los centros
educativos del país escuchemos las
palabras del presidente iraní
tus manos porque los enemigos porque
Estados Unidos y el régimensionista
conspiraron contra nuestra nación
nuestro país y nuestra Revolución y
crearon estos disturbios como dijo el
líder supremo nuestro país estaba
avanzando y los enemigos no quieren que
nuestro país progresen
y en otras noticias Corea del Norte
disparó un misil balístico sobre Japón
por primera vez en cinco años como
respuesta Tokio activo su sistema de
alerta antimisiles y emitió una inusual
advertencia para que la población
buscará Refugio los detalles en el
siguiente informe
era una mañana normal en Japón hasta que
ocurrió esto
tenemos noticias de última hora el
gobierno japonés advierte que Corea del
Norte parece haber lanzado al menos un
misil balístico existe la posibilidad de
que se dirija a Japón el gobierno me
está llamando a todos en el país a
permanecer en el interior o encontrar un
refugio inmediatamente
en todo Japón en pequeños pueblos y
grandes ciudades sonaron las sirenas
[Música]
junto con un mensaje omiso
un misil ha sido lanzado Corea del Norte
parece haber lanzado un misil
mensajes de advertencia llegaron a los
teléfonos los trenes de alta velocidad
se detuvieron abruptamente con el mismo
mensaje repetido en bucle
[Música]
se dio el visto bueno unos 20 minutos
después el misil cayó en el Pacífico
pero el daño estaba hecho el país estaba
sacudido y enfadado
vivo en un apartamento Así que no tengo
sótano cuando me dijeron que me pusiera
cubierto bajo tierra mi reacción sincera
fue realmente no sé qué hacer aunque no
haya sanciones quiero que el gobierno
adopte una postura más firme frente a
Corea del Norte
[Música]
me sentía asustada si su tecnología ha
mejorado significa que están trabajando
en ello a diario Me preocupa que algún
día puedan fabricar un misil potente
fue la primera vez que un misil
norcoreano sobrevoló Japón desde 2017
las autoridades calificaron en el
disparo como un acto imprudente y
dijeron que la distancia de vuelo
estimada de este misil en particular Era
la más larga entre los cohetes lanzados
anteriormente
volvemos a nuestra región en Nicaragua
la fiscalía acusa a 13 familiares de
opositores y otros detractores al
gobierno de Daniel Ortega por
propagación de información falsa y
conspiración los acusados están
detenidos e incomunicados en la cárcel
de el chipote nuestro corresponsal en
Centroamérica Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
nos cuenta más
tras varios días en prisión en la cárcel
el chipote de Managua varios familiares
de opositores al gobierno de Daniel
Ortega incluyendo dos francesas
recibieron la noticia que la fiscalía de
ese país centroamericano les había
imputado los cargos de noticias falsas y
de Conspiración y aquí destacamos el
caso de la familia de Javier Álvarez
Zamora declarado opositor pero sin
ninguna afiliación política ni relación
con los medios de comunicación el pasado
13 de septiembre la policía de
nicaragüense irrumpió en su casa en aras
de capturarlo pero este había escapado
horas antes a Costa Rica luego de que lo
hubiesen alertado de su captura de
manera que la policía resolvió arrestar
sin orden judicial a su esposa y a su
hija Yanine of the York y Ana Álvarez of
fideos ambas con ciudadanía doble de
Nicaragua y de Francia así como también
arrestaron a su yerno Félix Royce
organismos internacionales de Derechos
Humanos así como movimientos políticos
de oposición como la unidad nacional
azul y blanco denunciaron que se trata
de una nueva embestida represiva de
parte de Ortega ahora en contra de los
familiares de los opositores familiares
que ahora enfrentarán juicios que les
podrían acarrear años de cárcel y
procesos judiciales
característicos por no contar con
libertades del derecho a la defensa
y en Brasil tras la primera vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales Yair
bolsonaro y Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
entran en la recta final de Cara a la
campaña electoral para la segunda vuelta
del 30 de octubre con el objetivo de
llegar a los indecisos Lula convocó una
reunión de estrategia de campaña para
enfocar estas últimas semanas
el cambio de tu presidencial de la
izquierda Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
parecía estar a un paso de la victoria
en la primera vuelta electoral sin
embargo con solo 5 puntos porcentuales
de diferencia su rival de extrema
derecha el presidente Jair bolsonaro se
encuentra en una posición Igualmente
fuerte Lula no ha perdido el tiempo y
convocó una reunión estratégica para
vencer a su rivaldo
No necesitamos hablar con gente que ya
conocemos con gente que sabemos que ya
nos ha votado con gente que sabemos que
nos va a votar
hablaremos con aquellos que no parecen
gustarnos que no parecen botarnos que no
parecen gustar a nuestros partidos y es
con ellos Con quienes hablaremos
a pesar de quedar en segundo lugar El
presidente ayer por sunaro sorprendió a
muchos después de que su partido ganará
99 escaneos en la cámara baja y crece en
el senado con la mayoría conservadora en
el congreso por su Naruto su
determinación de superar a Lula en la
carrera final
nuestros adversarios solo se han
preparado para una carrera de 100 metros
nosotros estamos preparados para una
maratón lucharemos con confianza y con
fuerza creciente seguro que
prevaleceremos por la patria por la
familia por la vida por la libertad y
por la voluntad de Dios
ambos candidatos no solo tendrán que
mantener su impulsor sino también
convencer a los 31 millones de
brasileños que no votaron en la primera
vuelta para que imitan un voto a su
favor
Lula y Naruto se enfrentarán en un
debate televisado que podría ser
decidido antes de la segunda vuelta
final
vamos con información económica la bolsa
de Nueva York suspendió la cotización de
la acción de Twitter ya que los títulos
se valorizaban en más del 12% después de
que el portal especializado bloomberg
news asegurara que el multimillonario y
lo más iba a seguir adelante con la
compra de la compañía por 44 mil
millones de dólares recordemos que el
dueño de tesla está en una disputa legal
con la red social después de declarar
que ya no le interesaba el negocio la
suerte del multimillonario acuerdo será
sometida a un juicio de cinco días a
partir del 17 de octubre en un tribunal
empresarial de Delaware
y hoy se conoció el premio Nobel de
física 2022 que fue atribuido en partes
iguales a Alan aspecto closer y
anthonynger por sus descubrimientos en
mecánica cuántica los premiados sentaron
las bases para una nueva era de la
tecnología cuántica un factor clave en
este desarrollo es como la mecánica
cuántica permite que dos o más
partículas existan en lo que se llama un
estado entrelazado por ejemplo lo que le
sucede a una de las partículas determina
lo que le sucede a la otra partícula
Incluso si están muy separadas esto abre
la puerta a nuevas posibilidades de
transmisión de información
la Real Academia sueca de ciencias ha
decidido esta mañana otorgar el premio
Nobel de física 2022 en partes iguales a
ala aspe de Francia
de Estados Unidos y ante un silenger de
Austria recibieron el premio por
experimentos con fotones entrelazados
que establecieron la violación de las
desigua y fueron Pioneros en la ciencia
de la información cuántica
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en Francia 24 y 24.com
[Música]